alors que la saison de ski commence à
faire le plein d'amateurs de poudreuse
la petite ville de sto vite au rythme de
la fameuse tenzing pour josé daigneault
qui habitent aux états unis depuis
presque trente ans il ne reste que les
derniers préparatifs pour ces
retrouvailles annuelles en famille et
entre amis patrie du sénateur bernie
sanders le vermont représente toute une
variété d'opinions mais certains
hésitent à les partager autour de la
terre car en ces temps de procédure de
destitution
chacun a des opinions tranchées
difficile d'éviter le sujet politique
il y avait des familles qui vont
profiter des réunions pour parfois laver
leur linge sale comme on dit aux
familles on va les prendre un cocktail
tout à l'heure chez les voisins et puis
bon eux politiquement sans plus à droite
et ici c'est plus à gauche mais tout le
monde s'en tape à la fin de la soirée on
peut avoir des débats mais on est encore
tout ça ni cuisez un fait après un petit
verre d'apéritif
il suffit de prononcer le nom de donald
trump pour lancer le débat
ici ceux qui ont voté pour le président
il y a trois ans lui restent fidèles
pour les démocrates comme son propre
fils bryan aucun doute que le président
tron devrait être destitué
bref alors que la demande continue de
cuir le sort du président américain est
loin d'être déterminée il y aurait-il
une fatigue face à toute cette procédure
de destitution
peut-être
et parmi cette variété d'opinions parmi
les abstentionnistes les sceptiques les
démocrates ou les républicains purs et
durs qui pensent qu'elle devrait être
destitué
ah ok on an'a pas certaine la viande est
située la coupe est comme sa belle
grande trash ferme l'apéro chez les
voisins terminée le dialogue est ouvert
très loin de la politique partisane de
washington
en attaque c'est le petit peuple c'est
nous les gens qui continuent à nous et
il ya de montrer de la tolérance pour
passer à autre chose et l'esprit de
l'accès à moins d'un an des élections
des américains ont encore le temps de se
faire une meilleure opinion
ils sont cependant tous d'accord sur une
chose la dinde était excellent ici ça
d'eric arnould radio canada à ce taux
dans le vermont